Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call if you're new, just reminding you that you'll
be muted as you enter. If you have a question, you can chat it in or we finish all these
questions. You can unmute yourself and speak it in whichever is easier for you to do.
Reminder that the announcements are in the member site. So make sure you look at that. I
don't think there was any new announcements for this week. Let's jump into the question.
First question, when taking my supplements, can I take them with meals? Most of them, yes,
most of the supplements that you're taking, you could take them with meals. Sometimes that
can be easier on your stomach. The ones that are binders, typically I ask you to not take them
with a meal. But I have said, take that 30 minutes away from food or something like that,
homeopaths, you have to take away from food. So there are certain ones that I asked you to
take on a relatively empty stomach. Then just please follow that example. If you're on a high dose
enzyme therapy, you take that on an empty stomach. So just follow those instructions. Anyone else
where any other supplements where it doesn't say that you have to take another empty stomach,
you could assume that you couldn't take it with food in general, for sure. Okay, next question.
Since I spoke with you two weeks ago, I have had only one day without any panic attacks. I believe
it is because I had a handful of friends praying for me on that day,
I would have desperation. The panic is tormented. So this tells you the power of prayer that can be
extremely beneficial in anything, because God can change anything even our physiology,
since he is our stator of every cellular function that we have. But just I'm going to actually have
some videos up on the chronic disease and autoimmune site on this, but here's one of the slides here
unhealthy to understand what are called mood disorders. So don't be thrown by that terminology.
It doesn't mean you have a bad mood or something like that, but that's what's called a mood disorder
when you have depression, anxiety, CD, panic attacks. Those are all classified in the mood disorder
category. And here's one of the slides on this section that I will be doing soon and enter it in
might even be its own module on mood disorders in the chronic disease thing. So what are we looking
for when a person has panic attacks? Because we have several questions on panic attacks, anxiety,
and OCD the last few weeks. So there can be neurochemical imbalances, so you could have issues with
so neurochemicals. So when you're taking supplements, you're trying to alter chemistry. So when
you're taking a drug, you're trying to alter chemistry. So neurochemical, there's chemistry in your
brain. There's chemistry that alters nerve function. And you always think of neuro transmitters. Well,
that's just one piece of it. So it can be a neuro transmitter imbalance. So this talks about serotonin
imbalance, dopamine, gamma, acetylcholine, epinephrine. Those are all neuro transmitters. But there can be
other hormonal balances, imbalances there that are chemicals that affect the brain.
From, you know, we discussed, I think last week we had this question about hormone imbalances
that can affect the brain. Could be sugar imbalances. Could be neuro inflammation. There can be a grunt
gut-brained access disorder. All these things need to be ferreted out into their own slide
presentation. I have an entire presentation on neuro inflammation and microglial primate that goes
into one cause of any type of mood disorders, but it also is a cause of dementia issues. It's a
cause of Parkinson's issues. What you have inflammation in the brain from some reason that can affect
the microglial cells that can affect that you actually developing antibodies to neural tissue.
So we're going to add another question. I was asked what test do what kind of test do we test for
this? I'll get to that in just a second, but this is where we can test for antibodies to neural tissue.
So there's a Cyrex antibody test, Cyrex array 7x. That could be very valuable to really
get it into diagnosed. What is causing this? If it is, and basically an autoimmune issue in the brain,
you can have a brain injury issue. So a brain injury due to trauma, post-traumatic
injuries, post-concussive injuries, a lot of information on post-concussive syndrome.
First of all, that has had multiple minor concussions. I don't even remember being knocked out,
but I've played soccer for years in high school and college. You're heading the ball all the time.
You had all these little micro-biter concussions that then can now
affair it out as inflammation in the brain 15, 25 years later, and now you're having all these
issues that you never would have attributed back to that time. Or you had a very serious concussion.
I had a really bad car accident when I was 25. It took a long time to recover, but gosh,
that was 25 years ago. How can that be a cause of it? Well, you can have damage to microglial cells,
and then they can stay in this certain prime state where they're just spewed out inflammation,
and that can end up with other issues. Trauma or toxin exposure or emotional issues can then spark
an autoimmune issue. Now you've developed antibodies to neural tissue, and that's causing massive
symptom, symptomology. You can have neurodegenerative issues, so you can have degeneration in the brain.
Usually, again, that's caused from back to the neuroinflammation that was the piece of that,
but then causing antibodies to be developed to neural tissue, and then destructive
loss of myelin sheets or destructive loss of neural tissue, because every time you spark an
immune reaction, you're destroying that, which you have antibodies against it, if you have antibodies
against neural tissue, you're going to have destruction of brain matter. Then we get into the
neurodevelopmental disorders. That's not going to be anybody that we're really, really related to
here. That's going to be a younger person. Then you have psychological issues. We have issues of
stress. We have issues of emotional traumas, and that's where you get into post-traumatic stress
issues. All those play a part, and we can't... You've got a cancer diagnosis. That plays a huge part
into sparing on something that was already there, and maybe somewhat latent for a period of time.
Now you've got the stress of a cancer diagnosis, and it just spews on this inflammation and a greater
propensity towards these mood disorders that maybe you didn't have prior to this. Then you get
into the neurological autoimmune diseases that I touched out, and that's where testing for those
can be wise. That was the question about testing. Also, the things that you want to test for,
one of the other things on this slide was this gut brain access disorder. That's very, very common.
That's another thing to test for. Can parasites in the gut cause mood disorders? Yes, because that
could cause inflammation in the brain. Can a person get parasites in the brain? Yes, they can
back and cross the blood brain barrier. Can the source be like a vaccine that causes the
adjuvings across the blood brain barrier? Yes. Can toxins damage the blood brain barrier, and then
therefore cross the blood brain barrier and cause inflammation of the brain? Yes. So testing stool
sample for parasites, testing for pathogens, microtoxins, are a main cause of brain inflammation,
and microglial priming. So some of the tests that you would run besides antibody tests,
two-dural tissue, in the case that I mentioned, the CyRex 7x. Another test, you would run
would be parasite tests, and then food sensitivity tests. So if I have antibodies to, let's say,
gluten, or gliadine peptides, and I'm eating gluten every time I eat that, I'm causing an inflammatory
action in my gut, and then I actually have gluteal morphine receptors in my gut that fire in my brain.
I'm going to be causing inflammation in my brain, and it's like that with so many other foods, you
could be eating a good food, let's say broccoli, and I don't have any gut issues when I eat broccoli,
but if you have antibodies to broccoli, you're going to be causing inflammation in the brain every time
you eat that. So remember, inflammation in the gut is going to equal inflammation in the brain.
So if something is damaging, you're causing an inflammatory reaction, you're going to have
inflammation in the brain, and it is going to come out in different ways, depending upon any other
pre-existing issues that you have with lural tissue. So digging into doing some testing is the next step,
if you can't counteract it with just some, let's try to heal your gut, let's try to get rid of
inflammation, let's try to deal with parasites, it'd be better to run some labs to get to the
bottom of it. Okay, next question. Can you please explain the BU and the bun test on my lab work?
So the bun on your lab work that's typically seen on a comprehensive metabolic profile,
that stands for blood, urea, nitrogen, and it's a biomarker reflecting how you break down protein,
and how your kidneys are getting rid of it. So the simplest terminology, if you have an elevated
BU end, that means you have stress on your kidneys. So your kidneys are undergoing stress for some
reason. So it's not indicative of anything, you know, again, just like any test, it gives you
clues, but elevated BU end is their stress out of your kidneys, could it be because of kidney
dysfunction? So the kidneys could be dysfunctioning, so you could have renal disease
elevating your BU end. You could have something more simple, like even dehydration would elevate
your BU end. Hypochloridria, meaning decreased hydrochloric acid, and your stomach would elevate
BU end, because you're going to have incomplete breakdown of proteins in your gut.
You could have, it's things like access, you know, somebody who's on a
carnivore type diet where they're eating tons of meat, you know, more than normal. They will have
an elevated BU end. So you've got to break it down, you've got to look at lifestyle of that person.
You wouldn't automatically jump to renal disease, but again, so where would we see elevated BU end
with somebody who has a previous cancer diagnosis? You would have to look at how is this person
on a medication? Because medications can damage your kidneys, and then that can give you an elevated
BU end. So remember, all lab tests are clues to something else. So we've seen people on, you know,
chemotherapy, have an elevated BU end because the chemotherapy has damaged their kidneys,
and until that gets cleared out, and their kidneys can heal, they may have an elevated BU end.
We've had people with taking venbendazole, or Ivermectin, have an elevated BU ends.
Similar to them having an elevated alkaline phosphatase, AST, or ALT. Those are liver markers
showing that that is causing stress to the liver. So there's all sorts of things that can cause
stress to organs. So elevated BU end is going to say, hey, they're stressed to my kidneys.
What is causing it? Is it because of, I'm not properly breaking down proteins because I have a
decreased hydrochloric acid production in my stomach? Is it because I have dehydration? So I'm having
difficulty breaking down proteins, and I have elevated urea. Do I have kidney damage? Because of
a drug that I'm taking, even adrenal stress could cause elevated BU end, and edema could cause
elevated BU end. So if I have an excess edema due to, let's say, blockage of lymphatic flow could
cause an elevated BU end. So there's a lot of reasons why that you need to flush them up by looking at
the person's history. You need to flush them up by looking at what else is going on with this person
that could be leading to this. All blood tests give us clues. Next question. Can you explain to me
again why cancer patients shouldn't take metal supplements? Anatropathics that I should
said I have the MTHFR defect. So you have a lot of genes that we look at, and your MTHFR gene is one
of them. So that's the methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase gene, is what that stands for.
So that gene is at the end of the folate cycle. It takes five methylene THF and breaks it down
into ultimately to go into the methionine cycle, which at the end of that, you know, goes into the
glutathione cycle. So it is important to have your genes functioning, but even if I have a
double allele defect on my most important MTHFR gene, which is the C677 gene, it doesn't mean that I
should be on methyl groups. So again, when the genetics were first looked into, the MTHFR gene was
one of the first and more research genes. And it is when genetic tests first came out. Practitioners,
you know, there wasn't a whole lot known about them, but it was known that people with MTHFR gene
defects may have a more difficult time what was termed as methylating, meaning helping break down
the folate cycle to go into the methionine cycle. So then it was thought that everybody with an
MTHFR gene defect has deficiencies in methyl groups, so you should give them methyl groups. You should
give them methyl tetrahydrofolate. That's the type of folate that you should be giving these people,
and you should be giving them methyl comolomy. That's a type of B12. You should be giving these people.
And there can be dangers of that because we've learned a whole lot since that was first discovered
15 years ago. And there's a lot more genes to look at. That's one of the issues that I have with
a lot of these gene companies that just do little snippets like they might do 25 genes here and tell
you whether you have difficulty losing weight or 25 genes here and tell you if you have issues with
methylation because your body doesn't work that way. It doesn't work in little pieces. It doesn't
work in little compartments. Your whole folate pathway feeds into your methionine pathway which then
feeds into your trans-alpheration pathway and feeds into your biopterine pathway. And they're all
functioning in this perfect chemistry, or you could say this giant orchestra. So just
because we have an issue with one tuba player doesn't mean that we have to go and get five new tuba
players to play it. It's going to throw the whole symphony off. So you have to look at the big
picture when you're going to recommend supplementation based upon genetics. That's number one. So
number one, I would never tell a person because they have an MTHFR gene defect that you need to be
on methylated supplements. That's just wrong because if you put them on methylated supplements and you
didn't look at let's say the biopterine pathway and they and you didn't know that they also have
MAOA defects in the biopterine pathway and you add methyl groups. It will push that MAOA gene
if they have defects in that they will spill out a lot of serotonin and they will have excess
serotonin and they could have range issues and all sorts of moon disorders to go back to
balances, neurochemical and balances due to moon disorders can be because of something like that.
So I've seen this time and time again where a person you know was told because of one gene defect
that you need to be on this product and therefore it could tip over the whole symphony.
Little off track but the question was why should a cancer patient not take methyl supplements?
I just spoke to somebody today that was diagnosed with cancer and was going to a different
practitioner that practitioner had them on multiple supplements that had methyl comolamine and
methyl tetrahydrofolate. Well the problem with that is what you're going to ask what do methyl
so what do methyl groups do? So a methyl group member from chemistry is a carbon with three hydrogens
and it attaches to something. So when you're taking a supplement like methyl tetrahydrofolate it's
a methyl group attached to tetrahydrofolate so that is a form of folate. So taking a B12
is comolamine now you can take it attached to methyl so it's methyl comolamine or you can take
attracts to hydroxyl or a dental seal it's attached to other organic compounds or you're going to
take it attached to methyl. What's the advantage of that methyl group? Well that methyl group will break
off when you absorb that and it will be distributed through your body and it will attach to different
things and it has purposes so you need methyl groups. I'm not saying that but would we take excess
methyl groups? What do methyl groups do? Well methyl groups will attach to your DNA and will
turn genes off. Well we do need that. We do need genes turned off but we have excess methyl groups
when we have a diagnosis of cancer when we have excess methyl groups in the cell we can be turning
off tumor suppressor genes. Remember one way that you kill cancer is that you have this inside the cell
you have this component that God created that when you have cancer and that cell is it in in rapid
replication that cell will signal the tumor suppressor system and your tumor suppressor system will
turn on to destroy the cancer from the inside out that's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway. It
stimulates this capsaic reaction and it kills the cell destroyed it through apoptosis from the inside
out and that's how you're protected from getting a cancer diagnosis if you if you don't have one.
So and when you have cancer that's one way that you will kill the cell and destroy cancer for the inside
out it's that intrinsic apoptotic pathway and it's hindered by you having excess methyl groups
intracellularly how would you have that by taking too many methyl supplements that in fact there's
some chemotherapies that the way they work is they block the methylation pathway so that you're not
producing excess methyl groups in the cell so that you're helping and you're allowing the natural
intrinsic apoptotic pathway to take place by the stimulation of tumor suppressor genes and
you're helping kill cancer so a cancer patient should not be taking methylated supplements
unless we're dealing with other comorbidities as a person could have a comorbidity of elevated
homocysteine and the way you bring down a homocysteine is by using methyl groups for a period of time
but if you don't have elevated homocysteine you should not be taking methyl groups as a cancer patient
hopefully that helps I do have some other lectures on that to help understand that but I think I spoke too much
next question at one point should of course person be concerned about their cholesterol levels so
you know back when I graduated way back when the normal cholesterol I think at that time was 220 maybe
it was even 250 at that time and then they came up with this drug called lipitor and they got a ton of
people on lipitor because people had elevated cholesterol and then cholesterol became the bad guy that
started eating blame for heart disease because heart disease number one killer in America so it's all
because of cholesterol and we need to lower cholesterol and got everybody on lipitor well it didn't change
the fact that people still you know had placking in the arteries and and still died of heart disease but
you won't hear that too much in the mainstream media and then they thought well we could get a whole lot
more people on lipitor and sell a whole lot more of this drug if we lower the normal cholesterol they
lowered it down to 200 is the normal cholesterol and then they thought again well if we just start putting
people on lipitor if they're above 180 we can make a whole lot more buddy and that's kind of
this scenario I don't want to be cynical about it but that's just the truth so what is a good cholesterol
well you actually need cholesterol cholesterol is not this bad guy remember there's very few things
that are in our body that is circulating through our streams that is all bad or all good it's all
about balance the cholesterol is all about balance too well what is the normal balance of cholesterol
well the normal balance of cholesterol is anywhere between 160 and really maybe 300 so I would not
actually when I look at somebody's blood work if I'm not really concerned about their cholesterol
less their cholesterol is you know in the 300s you know high 300s really which you're really looking
at is the triglycerides and you're looking at other things too remember every blood every blood
chemistry marker is just giving you clues so yes if a person has cholesterol in 290 that could be a
clue of something else that's going on I'm not again concerned about the cholesterol and concerned
about the clue that it's giving us you know is there issues with congestion in the liver that that
person is putting out too much cholesterol person can have a genetic hyper cholesterolemia where they're
just make excess cholesterol they just don't get rid of it that's just from a genetic issue that
you can't really do anything about but a person can have elevated cholesterol because of dysfunction in
the liver but far as damage of the cholesterol to placate at the arteries you're looking at high
homocysteine levels that's more of a marker triglycerides other inflammatory markers like ferritin
and iron would give you more clues of whether there's inflammation going on and then arterial inflammation
going on so I'm not really concerned about cholesterol levels I'm concerned about the clue that it
gives us of course it's if it's way over 300 then that's something we need to pay more attention to
but if it's 250 to me that's still normal again if it's 250 and you have way elevated triglycerides
that's abnormal but it's not the cholesterol is the triglycerides it's the arterial inflammation
that I'm concerned about not the cholesterol itself can parasites get into your brain and cause issues
I did address that on that last question but the answer is yes so you do have a blood
brain barrier that is actually created by your astrocytes which is a type of glial cell that wraps
around your blood vessels that go through your brain and its purpose is to keep things from getting into
the neuro cavity that shouldn't get into the neuro cavity the problem is is that you can damage
those cells and you can have a damaged blood brain barrier so a damaged blood brain barrier is
not a whole lot different than a damaged gut barrier hence forth the name permeable gut or leaky gut
you can have a leaky brain a damaged blood brain barrier it's very common and things can get into that
into the brain that you don't want to get into the brain like just circulating toxins or
or you know things that you're exposed to in parasites are one of those that's the real
damaging part about getting your child vaccinated before they're three years old I don't think
she should get vaccinated at all but that's my opinion why should you be even more careful
of what your child is exposed to in general before they're three years old because you don't have a
blood brain barrier tell your three years old you have a non-existent blood brain barrier for a six
month old and you're injecting all these poisons into them with all these adjabings that go right
across because there's no blood brain barrier and it's damaging the brain and it's causing neuro
inflammation and now they're having issues five years later you know two months later 10 years later 30
years later because of that damage to the brain so anything that gets across that barrier or
that nonexistent barrier or a damaged barrier can cause damage to the brain and it can be parasites can
be toxins either first step is it's going to damage microglial cells that's the scampaging immune
system detoxifier lymphatic system of the brain those microglial cells get damaged they can stay in a
primed condition where they spew out of inflammation that causes more problems can cause all sorts of
symptoms depending on where those damaged microglial cells are in the brain if they're in the
primal lobe they're going to cause more symptoms like pain and numbness and tingle if it's in the
frontal lobe it could cause confusion and forgetfulness and executive function issues if it's in the
amygdala it's going to cause more mood disorders and PTSD issues and it's in the occipital areas
can cause site issues and if it's in a temporal area can cause you know anywhere from auditory
issues to so depending on where that damage is being spewed out is where the person's going to have
symptoms and then it moves to a greater issue because then you can end up developing antibodies to
neural tissue and that's what we would see in a Cyrex 7x test so yes the answer is yes
next question one of the best ways to detoxify past vaccines I've had I've started
I'm starting to read more and more about the dangers of these that I've foolishly had
well the best way to detoxify vaccines go back to everybody has access to the
seven phases of detox course so we all want like a quick fix I just want what is what should I take
you know what what's the magic supplement for this or that are killing parasites or getting rid
of vaccines it's just not that simple so you need to support all the detox pathways so it's really
important for me not to give that simple fix like or just tag zeolite or you just need EDTA
as a key later or you just need to take you know full mac acid uh it's not that simple and it's
it would be inappropriate for me to say that because you have to support all those pathways you got to
make sure you're having good bowel movements uh daily bowel movements and you're really empty
your gut you got to make sure that you're binding things in the gut that's phase five phase six was the
bowel movements you got to make sure that your bile isn't blocked and that you got good bile
movement and your bile is not super viscous so you have good bile function good gall bladder function
that's phase four you got to make sure that you're creating bile so that you are able to to bind toxins
from the liver that you're trying to pull out of other parts in your body um that's phase three
and phase one and two were the main detoxification phases that we look at when we look at your genetics
so we look at your genes do we need to support the side of pro p450 pathways and or the pond pathways
and then 80 pathways etc that's phase one and phase two how you actually take toxins from your blood
through your liver to help break them down into soluble water soluble forms distributed into the
bile and then get it in and through the bile duct so the gall bladder that dumped into the
duodenum that it goes out it doesn't get reabsorbed it gets into the toilet so then when you got that
all working correctly then you could work on doing some chelation therapy to grab it out of the tissues
uh in a way that's not going to just spill it elsewhere in the blood and cause all sorts of symptoms
you got to go slow with that so it is a process you you've had a process of becoming toxic it's
going to be a process of detoxified it's not a matter if I did this brox detox for two weeks now I'm
detoxified no you're constantly being toxified so you have to be constantly detoxified so your level
of toxicity is equal to your level of toxic exposure minus your ability to get rid of it so you're
constantly working on that we live in a toxic world and we're constantly dealing with this so
so go to the course to help you understand that you know and you know we can't be pulling a whole
bunch of stuff out of the tissue when we're trying to kill cancer too because we could be spilling
stuff we have to be careful and do this slowly is your easy peasy way of doing coffee
enemas as effective as the traditional light on your side method it sure is a lot simpler okay so remember
the purpose of doing coffee enemas the purpose of doing coffee enemas is not to have a bowel movement
your purpose of doing coffee enemas is to help stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system
to help stimulate the flush sheet of your liver to help stimulate you know uptake of your
immune system to help kill cancer cells help kill infection and to help stimulate your parasympathetic
to help calm your brain calm your body slow your heart rate calm everything down and that is the
purpose of doing a coffee enemas side effect of doing a coffee enemas is if you're constipated it can
help you get rid of stuff in your colon so is the easy peasy way of doing coffee enemas as effective
so we're just trying to get the caffeine into our rectum to stimulate the parasympathetics you have
parasympathetic vagal nerve exposure in the rectum so if we get it in there what doesn't really
this do we really need to be lighted our back lighted and our turning to our side to get it to
no you really don't I'm very much in favor of my easy peasy way if you don't know what I'm
talking about it's listed in the member site it's listed in the detox course it's listed in several
courses my easy peasy way of doing coffee enemas standing in the shower it just makes life a lot easier
and I think a lot of people don't do coffee enemas because it's such a pain it can be messy and
takes time of my day and I'll do it tomorrow we don't do it but if you could do it in the shower
every day and to step out go to the bathroom and void and then step back in the shower clear yourself
out you can wash the enemas thing out in the shower while you're finishing your shower and literally
added a few minutes to your shower so much simpler you're going to be much more apt to do it
than it could be so much more beneficial for you I have a couple bottles of a sia that are still
good is it okay to take with horrible positive breast cancer so that is a nutritional product
that is about balance seed basically kind of an electrolyte type balance yeah that's fine to take
there's no I don't think there's any harm in taking that I've ordered Sarah peptidase
Sarah peptidase capsules to get rid of die off of parasites while I am on ivermectin and fed mendazole
what those are your recommend and how often so Sarah peptidase is an enzyme so typically a person
would take Sarah peptidase at least one function of Sarah peptidase can help break up biofilm
so does it get rid of die off of parasites it might I'd not say that there's not websites that
are selling Sarah peptidase that say that it just don't think that that's the purpose of taking it
you're helping to break up biofilm of Sarah peptidase with any enzyme there's really no
no downside in taking literally any enzyme so dosage of that I don't on the top of my head have a
dosage you can't you really can't OD on enzymes so if you're trying to have it cross the gut border
um to use you know throughout your bloodstream then it's best to take that any enzyme that you
want across the book that you want it to work outside of the intestinal tract it's best to take it
with out food so it's best to take that on an empty stomach so that last that one question should
I take my supplements on uh with food or an empty stomach if you're going to take it with food
which most supplements are just fine with because they're mainly food-based supplements
they're herbs that are trying to stimulate you know your immune system etc
it's fine to take those with food but if you're trying to get something to absorb that otherwise
could work in the intestinal tract if there's food there like an enzyme that you want to take that on
an empty stomach I'm taking MCP which is modified citrus pectin powder you suggested with the green
string I happen to have a couple models of MCP capsules by pectosol that I ordered before I started
to cutters clinic would that be okay to take them to help with inflammation and panic yes so
pectosol um it's modified citrus pectin and it has a lot of beneficial effects on your body with
collected three I have a whole multiple videos just on that um but it is also a key later so
well modified citrus pectin falls into my category of mild to moderate key later so it's actually
really beneficial to help grab stuff and pull stuff out of your body there's just literally no
downside to modified citrus pectin so you could take that outside of uh in uh of your green drinks
at different at a different time yes lately I've seen a lot of ads for a product or herb called
happy saffron which is used for variety things but especially depression and cognitive issues
wouldn't be okay to take with hormone positive breast cancer and I'm also on an SSRI
yes I think that would be just fine the only issue that I have with that is
is I have seen that ad um and my only issue with that is saffron isn't extremely expensive for
um and I question the purity of the product or how much is actually in that but that's just my
skepticism um because it is a very expensive uh I think the most expensive herb there is so
I just don't know how much it's in that but if it works it works so okay your questions
from the chat I'm due for a recheck cheek swab since you added fenment almost a month ago
you indicated a recheck in four weeks it'll be four weeks on Friday I'm also having
full blood in a UA on Friday and tumor markers lab drawn on Monday I want to be able to talk to you
about that afterwards would you rather view all the labs before you do the cheek swab just to know
just want to know yeah I think we should probably wait and tell you all your labs back then look
at them and then we'll do the cheek swab good idea do you know how to read the guardian 360 lab I just
got the results back in him no idea what it means I have not discussed with the oncologist yet but I
know this I know his interest in the results is what drugs to try on me if I go that route yes you
can send that to me as well can I wear the hedron pendant around my neck since I have a pacemaker
yes yes that's not gonna throw off your pacemaker so the hedron uh things that you put on your phone
hedron you know things that you have in your home and the in the pendant aren't blocking e-mf's it's
helping change the e-mf's to to make a milder to your body so it won't have any effect on your pacemaker
since you were discussing hen trauma our two boys were in a single vehicle accident yesterday oh my
goodness everybody be trained for them their vehicle rolled at least five times and by the grace of
god they were both okay they both had CT scans and everything is okay in their head and neck but
obviously suspected concussion for both anything that I should be doing for them to help their brain
trauma I've been giving them article and other homeopathic for head trauma so I would say yes
article and a homeopathic for head trauma would be the thing to do but with acute concussions
the you need to put them on um fish oil so EPA DHA um fairly high dose like 3,000 milligrams you
need to put them on uh anti-inflammatory so if you have the um flavonoid clear inflame I would do high
dose of that like nine to twelve a day of that if you don't if you have curcumidate home
get them on at least 3,000 milligrams of curcumid try to get Boswellia and Resveratrol and green TX
tract as well and then progesterone can be extremely beneficial in acute um hand traumas so um it has
been shown to decrease acute inflammation in the brain progesterone um now the the issues with progesterone
is that um getting it the sourcing it um about a year and a half ago the FDA came after every
nutritional company that was selling progesterone cream in the progesterone uh serum that you it's
progesterone is typically used topically so you'd use the serum on your belly or the cream on your
belly um but that just got less lighted up again so now you could get it quick silver has a good progesterone
um uh and I think we have that on our store too and just take it as directed out there and you
would just take that for a period of time now progesterone you know it's like well they're they're boys
why should they be take the progesterone it's to help with the inflammation of the brain so I would
take that for probably a month with them the rest of those things that I mentioned I would stay on
for at least three months post concussive syndrome um that we mentioned with brain inflammation you
should probably watch that video know probably scary and brain inflammation and microbial
private if you just look up on our website pretty sure it's on the member site I know it's on
that all chronic disease and autoimmune site but it's definitely on our website if you just start
searching brain inflammation I think it is as you'll see the video it's on a half hour video that
explains what that is and how to deal with it mainly you know a couple years later but to and a cute
I don't really go through a cute trouble with that but I just explained that so yes with the cute
concussive syndrome those are the things that you would look at and you're you want to try to
decrease that inflammation because you don't want you know long-term issues that are going to
cause issues and they should probably go into a chiropractor that takes X-rays next question you
suggested taking coconut oil for brain issues um was that liquid or solid so coconut oil could be
extremely beneficial for brain issues too because the brain is made up of fats right so you need good
fats it's really important to have good fats that in fact I used I like telling this one story
oh years and years ago um when I was in I was think I was doing clinicals at the time so this
was the long time ago there was a baby that was brought into clinicals that had what was called at
that time floppy baby syndrome that was actually that was actually a disease in the medical systems
mind floppy baby syndrome this baby could sit up and I think it was I can't remember the details but
this baby was well you know a year later that this person this baby should have been sitting up
and their parents would sit him up and he just literally fall over he just literally fall over he was
happy nothing like that it was just he could he had no tone no muscle tone um and all we did is give
him coconut oil so we gave him coconut we didn't we gave him fish oil at the time and um
and literally the next visit which was the next week he was he was crawling so it was like
unbelievable transformation and it was suggested because what the time we're thinking this they were
on some low this was the low fat diet was really big and the mom was breastfeeding but she was on this
low fat diet because she wanted to lose her baby fat and um so this this baby was getting no fats um
and uh so you need that so sorry but your question was coconut oil should I be taking that as a
liquid or a solid so just you could just buy a tub of organic coconut oil at Costco and or your grocery
store just get organic coconut oil and at and if it liquefies because your house is really warm
you know then that's fine usually it's stable to a hundred and some degrees but otherwise
it's going to be like uh it's going to look like a crisco or something so you just want to take a
table spoon of that and go put down and this person's referring to a study that was out a number of
years ago where they actually took um uh I can't remember how many I think it was like 30 patients
that had dementia and um and in order to diagnose dementia there was a little memory test that
they had to take and and they were you know were you know graded out of that memory tested for 30 days
they took uh I can't remember two or three tablespoons of coconut oil that's that was all they did
and um they were separated into a couple groups I think 30 were in the test group that were taking
the coconut oil all 30 of them scored higher out of their test um all of them did just by taking
coconut oil so um it just tells you the need for fat to the brain when you're not these low fat
diets and stuff it's just very damaging to your immune system it's very damaging to your neural
function um and it's not good for you so getting good fat in your brain can be extremely helpful and
you can see you can see a turnaround in things quickly next question would you take ivermecta do you
take the calculated daily dose all at once or divided i looked up the half-life for ivermecta
it's 18 hours so the half-life is 18 hours then it's you still have half of it in your system at 18
hours that's a very long half-life considering the residual has a half-life of about five minutes so
when you take a hundred milligrams of resveratol assuming that you absorbed a hundred milligrams for a
sake of argument here in five minutes you only have 50 milligrams left in your system literally it goes
by that fast that's why you need to be taking it throughout the day that's why all your flavonoids and
things when you're taking clear inflame for your brain you want to break it up into you know pieces
through the day and any other supplements many of them don't have a long half-life 18 hour half-life
is a very long half-life so taking it all at once would be just fine our calcium heart scans
worth the radiation i have high-hole molassistine and low triglycerides and high apple B so high
apple B is another cardiac function that that is concerning the low triglycerides is positive
high-hole molassistine is concerning calcium heart scans will tell you any blockages
that have calcified so that was a scan that came out about 20 years ago I think because I remember
I got a letter from the local MRI place saying that they would do it on they gave it sent these
letter of letters out to doctors that they would do free these free scans you know we were in the
hopes that we would refer patients for those you know I never did that I can't remember if it's a CT
or an MRI I can't remember because I'd ever referred people for that can it be valuable well sure
it can't be valuable so you know if you have concerns I think that's that's certainly a whole lot less
invasive than going in with the scope and seeing how what kind of blockage you have so yeah I mean if
that was recommended to you you you and again if that's a CT scan you're going to have radiation
that goes along with that if it's an MRI you're going to have probably contrast time but
apple B is a heart by products to fat so you got your cholesterol okay so you're standard
blood test for you know cardio blood test the most basic it's going to have cholesterol
high-density lipoproteins low-density lipoproteins triglycerides well that's pretty
elementary so when you get into deeper tests you're going to break down those low-density lipoproteins
into apple proteins and then you're going to break them down into oxidized lipoproteins so that's
what you get into a more depth cardio study you know if a person you typically would only do that
as a person has you know super high elevated cholesterol or triglycerides or they you know had a
cardiac event or they have you know you know other issues that they that they want to dig deeper and
make sure they're you know what's going on with those levels so it's a CT scan.
Is there radiation with that you know but it can give you some peace of mind again remember
nothing's perfect so even if that all came back fine it still doesn't need everything's perfect
and again remember is it heart blockage that is is it arterial blockage that's causing
the the decreased blood flow or is it constriction of the arteries well it's both so I mean
I mean you all probably personally know somebody that went in and got a full
ethanol work up and they said my gosh you could drive a mac truck through your arteries a two
days later they have a massive heart attack and done well what's up with that because the the the
physical blockage of the artery is only one piece of it you can have constriction of the muscles
and that's usually due to you know H. Pylora or heavy metal toxicity or Lyme disease that's causing
damage to the ACE receptors and causing constriction of the the edithelial arterial system
and then that's just constricting the arteries and blocking it so there's different reasons why a person
would have you know cardiac event so and so but yeah it can still give you some peace of mind
uh to that you're at a higher risk because of calcified um you know edithelial cells or calcification
unbreeding the edithelial cells so there can be some um concern about that okay I think with that
we'll wrap up tonight thanks everybody for being a hug and thanks for getting your questions in
a lot of good questions hopefully I gave you some interesting advice and um we're back next week
God bless we'll be sharing um um and I do want to make one comment you know everybody saw everybody's
questions on here um you know for that person that's struggling with anxiety and panic and things
and how it was changed and they had some relief when there was prayer power of prayer is it's so
instrumental if you guys will please the purpose of these zoom calls is to be shared with one another
and to to learn from one another and hopefully learn from me a little bit but it's also to be
reminded to be praying for one another so everybody's at a different level of their care and
where their cancer's at let your cancer drive you to be a prayer warrior not just for yourself but
for others and see everybody on here as what are your purposes and be part of this clinic is to
learn how to pray for others so please be prayed for everybody um this as well as your family and
your loved ones and such thanks so much God bless we'll talk next week